but before that happens we thought we
would check in on someone who would
spend his life in the state and has seen
it change longitudinally over more than
50 years Adam curl is our friend he
joins us tonight to respond to a
potential Gavin Newsom presidential run
Adam what he's your Governor what do you
think of this
all right I I could barely watch that
without crawling out of my skin or not
being clean and sober okay couple things
he came on my podcast nine years ago and
he told me his number one issue was
homeless and homelessness he was that
was his number one issue I said to him
the homeless population this is 10 years
ago is comprised of drug addicts and
people with mental disabilities and or
both he then said to me sitting three
feet across from me but what about the
true face of homelessness which is a
mother of three who has a full-time
minimum wage job whose husband left her
so that was his idea of solving a
problem and he declared himself the
number one issue is homelessness and
that's what he thought Homeless was in
California of course it's grown
exponentially and no one has ever seen a
mother of three with a full-time job out
on the street he's a sociopathic buffoon
but the scary part is people vote for
him it's really you and I we don't need
to Solve the Riddle of Gavin Newsom he's
a carpet bagger he's an idiot he's
bought and sold he's a sociopath he puts
Brill cream on his teeth fine why do
people vote for him that's the real
question that we need to solve
well that's the threat to democracy
right there if you have a population
it's a brand new population a huge
percentage of Californians just got
there from other countries if you have a
population that votes for a leader that
makes things worse that is the challenge
to democracy and make things worse
measurably like measurably economically
in in crime I mean like that's a huge
problem a scary problem
yeah you know it's interesting the great
Carol Shelby the man who made the Shelby
Cobra left Texas in the 60s to come to
California to build cars could you
imagine leaving Texas and coming to
California to manufacture something in
2023. also here's a thought experiment
that I think would work do you think if
a number of Joe Biden's aides said to
him you can't run for president we're
already in our second term
do you think he would believe that
okay that's good well I don't run into
Biden too often but if I ever see him
I'm going to say that you know the
Constitution just won't allow it sir I'm
sorry
um Adam Carolla
that is hilarious performing in New York
in May good luck there great to see you
tonight
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight